MICHAEL BOLIN: Hello.
Good afternoon.
Welcome to, I guess,
what is the last
session of Google I/O.
I'm here to talk to you about
a topic that's near and dear
to my heart, which is JavaScript
programming in the
large with Closure tools.
My name's Michael Bolin.
As you can see I have my
SpeakerMeter URL up there if
you want to give me feedback.
I do talk about Closure a bit,
so feedback would be great.
But let's get started.
So first of all, something I
would actually like to clarify
is who am I and why did
they let me up here?
Because actually, I don't
work at Google.
I used to work at Google.
And while I was there I worked
on Google Calendar.
I did a lot of the front-end
development for that.
And then also then the majority
of the front-end
development on Google Tasks.
And then post-Google I wrote
a book called Closure:The
Definitive Guide.
Maybe some you have it.
And basically around
the time when--
about a year and a half ago--
when Google Open Sourced
Closure, I just felt very
strongly that this is a really
important toolkit.
In terms of moving the web
forward, in terms of enabling
people to make really fast
web applications.
And that's what makes the web
better for everyone, when
people can build higher
quality applications.
So I've done a bit of work in
the realm of doing some large
JavaScript development.
And that's what we're going
to talk about today.
So first I should clarify--
or at least give some sort of
definition-- for what I mean
by programming in the large.
Just to throw out--
I'm just going to make up some
numbers-- but more properties,
let's say 30,000
lines of code.
Let's say that's programming
in the large.
Another aspect is having
a large team.
Once you have more people--
because you need more people
to build a bigger
application--
now you also have this
communication overhead that
you have to think about.
I think that this is really
important in terms of
JavaScript because a lot of
people are used to just
copying and pasting some code
they find on the web to
decorate some page that they
have and that's kind of what
their impression of what
JavaScript programming is.
And they don't really have an
idea of how to get to the 10
lines of code they copied to
the 30,000-line JavaScript
application.
And another aspect of this is
a longer development cycle.
This is significant in terms
of, if you work at a larger
company people may roll
on and off your team.
They're going to have to be able
to pick up and dive into
a large code base that they're
not familiar with.
Also over a six-month period,
you, yourself, may not even
remember what the code that
you did six months ago.
So it needs to be organized.
You need to have some way of
laying it out such that you
can come back to it, anyone else
can come into it because
this is what's going to enable
you to build more complex and
interesting applications.
Not that everything needs
to be complex.
Absolutely not.
But there's a certain class of
applications that are really
interesting that we want to
see brought to the web.
And for that, it just takes a
different, you need to take a
different tack in terms of how
you organize your team and
organize your code to
make sure you can
make interesting progress.
So this the area that I'm
calling JavaScript programming
in the large.
And that's where, I think,
Closure really fits in and
speaks to that.
So today if you wanted to
build a rich internet
application, or an RIA, a lot
of these are thought of a
single-page applications.
Such as Gmail and Calendar,
where you go, you log in, you
actually don't really reload
the page or change URLs.
Maybe the fragment changes and
it keeps track of your state.
But you load a large bundle of
JavaScript at the beginning.
Perhaps you navigate through
the app, exercise certain
features, more JavaScript
gets loaded.
But basically you're using
this one thing where
everything is in memory
on that single page.
So if you wanted to create
this rich experience,
something that's more akin to a
desktop app, obviously we're
doing a lot of stuff with
HTML5 right now.
But let's think about what some
of your options would be.
So the first one is use a
plugin, such as Java or Flash.
Some people may remember Java
applets, which were going to
be the greatest thing and they
were going to save the web and
we were going to be able to
write all our things in Swing
and they were all going to be
purple and gray and it was
going to be great.
But the problem was, it took
like half an hour or something
for that Java plugin to load and
you were looking at that
coffee cup.
Assuming you could even figure
out how to download it.
And then Flash.
Flash is obviously a lot
snappier than Java.
And is very popular today.
Obviously when YouTube first
came out, I don't know if
there would have been a YouTube
if there weren't a
Flash plugin.
But certainly Apple has thrown
down the gauntlet.
An iOS Flash is a non-starter.
So if you want to have a code
base that you can use across
different devices and supporting
iOS is important to
you, than Flash is not really
a reasonable option.
Another option, which is good
for building an RIA, is GWT.
Obviously I'm sure there's
a lot of people
here who use GWT.
Certainly a lot of people at
this conference have been
talking a lot about GWT.
And so, if you're familiar with
it, the idea is basically
that you write your application
in a language
that's more familiar to you.
In the case of GWT, it's Java.
And then the tool takes care of
translating your Java code
into JavaScript.
And certainly a lot of people
have written a lot of
interesting things with GWT.
Even this morning, I believe,
the Angry Birds folks said
that their stuff is
written in GWT.
So clearly you can get
a lot done using it.
But at the same time, there's
actually a lot of really great
things that JavaScript has that
Java doesn't have. Such
as first-order functions, is a
really big one and a really
natural use of Closure's.
Passing a function around as a
parameter in Java is actually
incredibly awkward.
Yet it's also very
straight-forward when you do
it in JavaScript.
Similarly there's APIs of the
browser, with HTML5, new
things are coming out
all the time.
In JavaScript you can use these
things very directly.
In GWT you need to wrap them in
JSNI or someone else has to
do that work for you.
So if you really care about
getting close to the mettle of
the browser, so to speak, GWT
has ways to get to it.
But it's not as natural as if
you were using the language
that the browser speaks,
which is JavaScript.
The way that I propose, and
have built, rich internet
applications is writing
lots of JavaScript.
Because it is awesome.
And when I say lots,
I do mean lots.
The last project I worked on
we wrote 70,000 lines of
JavaScript was our
application.
And we did it using Closure.
As I mentioned, JavaScript has
first-order functions.
It also has regular expression
literal, similar to Perl.
It has a prototype- based
inheritance mechanism that
Java does have and other
languages don't have. It
actually took that-- it was
inspired by this other
language called Self.
So there's a lot of neat things
that you get when you
write in JavaScript, in
addition to being
close to the browser.
But also as a language, it
is a very good language.
People have bad impressions of
it because they only associate
it with browser programming,
which is traditionally
fundamentally difficult
because of things like
Internet Explorer 6 and all the
differences in the DOM.
It's the DOM API that's actually
the source of most
people's frustration.
But JavaScript the language
really takes more of the heat,
whereas it should not.
In case you think I'm the only
person who is crazy, who
thinks we should write a lot
of JavaScript, all these
applications on the bottom that
Google has written, they
are in JavaScript.
A lot of people assume that
the Google Web Toolkit is
responsible for everything
that Google produces.
That's not the case.
Part of it was also just
due to history.
Some of these applications had
already been built up and were
going and rewriting
it in GWT--
doesn't seem like
a good option.
But also, sometimes there
are just performance
characteristics or metrics
that we wanted these
applications to meet.
And it just made a lot of
sense to write them in
JavaScript.
And all these are basically
powered by Closure.
So at the same time I'm telling
you that you should
write a lot of JavaScript, yet
in some ways JavaScript tries
to defeat programming
in the large.
So unlike Java, there's
no namespaces.
There's no import statement that
is part of the language
in JavaScript.
And namespaces are important
because as you build up a lot
of code, you need some
way to modularize it.
You need some way
to organize it.
Namespaces turn out to be a
pretty good mechanism for
doing that sort of thing.
Visibility controls are another
important point.
In particular, in terms of
object oriented programming
you have-- in Java you have
the private public
protected key words.
You're saying, this data should
only be seen by the
methods that belong
to this class.
This also is helpful in
programming in the large.
Because then this further helps
you modularize your
code, modularize data.
And it's enforced
by the compiler.
So you get some static
checking about this
organization and you don't have
to manage it yourself.
Similarly, having
a type system.
A lot of people like the idea
that JavaScript is, what many
people call, duck type.
That if you get an object and it
has the properties that you
want, then you can use it the
way that you want to.
As opposed to having to create
an explicit class and having
methods with strongly typed
signatures saying, this takes
a string, this takes a number
and the compiler won't let you
do anything that violates
that contract.
But as you write more and more
JavaScript and you just pick
up people's code and you're
just trying to look at the
interface, this can actually
be kind of difficult.
I, myself, find this someone
troubling when I look at
Python documentation.
Python's also both not
strongly typed.
A lot of times what the method
does would be more obvious if
I just knew the type signature
that were associated with it.
So as you write more
and more code this
can become a problem.
It's also related to
refactoring, which I will
probably get into later.
Also static checking.
So this is related to having
a type system.
When you have a type system and
you have a compiler that
enforces types that means at
compile time, the compiler can
help you find a whole class of
errors that you might not find
while running your problem.
But similarly if you have an
error in an else branch--
I'm sure many Python
programmers
have hit this problem--
or any branch of code, I should
say, where it's not
executed regularly.
Or say some sort of error
handling code.
Because obviously you want to
test with good inputs and no
one ever tests their
bad inputs.
Because why would we ever
have bad inputs?
But that people don't find out
until run time until someone
finally happens to trigger
that error.
There's a large class pf
problems that happen there
that could be checked statically
if there were a
compiler or some sort of other
static analysis tool to
perform that checking for you.
Again programming in the large,
as your code gets
bigger and bigger it's really
hard to manage all these
things yourself.
Yes, you should be writing
unit tests or integration
tests that actually exercise
all these code paths.
But the reality is that most
people don't, assuming they
write tests at all.
And this last one is not having
built-in support for templates.
So in JavaScript, or any web
application, you're usually
building up large
strings of HTML.
Because this is the thing that
you use to create your user
interface in a web browser,
is basically HTML and CSS.
Unfortunately in JavaScript,
we don't
have multi-line strings.
Yet we want to create large DOM
structures defined in HTML.
And then we would really like
to have placeholders, so we
could basically have
a template and
substitute things in.
If you have a repeated row
in a table, right?
You'd like that row to be a
template that you can just
reuse and pump out the same
structure HTML but with
different variables.
And unfortunately the way
strings work in JavaScript
today, it's not so
straightforward to do that
sort of thing.
So these are some of the ways
that JavaScript tries to
defeat or makes it harder to do
development in the large.
There's a suite of tools Open
Sourced by Google called the
Closure tools.
And that's what the crux
of my talk is about.
And these tools are useful
in general in JavaScript
development.
But I think their true strength
is when you start
doing JavaScript development
in the large.
And that, obviously,
you should start
with a small project.
It's not a good idea to start
with a big project.
So at the outset you may not see
the value in these tools.
But you might then get to a
point where you really wish
you had been using them.
So let's look at
what they are.
The first one is the
Closure Library.
The Closure Library is a library
of common utilities,
widgets, written
in JavaScript.
It works across browsers.
It works back to IE6.
So it's analogous to your
jQueries queries, your
MooTools, your YUI all
that sort of thing.
All these things are JavaScript
libraries that try
to abstract away browser
differences from you and
provide a lot of common
functionality.
The next tool is Closure
Templates.
So Closure Templates is
a templating language.
Because we didn't have enough
templating languages.
But Closure Templates does
have some unique
and important features.
And you can use it to--
as I mentioned, it's hard to
build up strings of HTML in
JavaScript using
raw JavaScript.
But having a separate template
language actually makes this a
lot easier and also less
error-prone, as we'll see.
And the third tool is the
Closure Compiler.
The Closure Compiler is
a JavaScript minifier.
So that means that you may write
your JavaScript full of
comments and white space that
don't actually contribute to
the behavior of your program.
But your users, who download the
JavaScript when they visit
your site, they're paying the
penalty, so to speak, of
download time and parse
time when you
have these extra bytes.
And so you want to use a
JavaScript minifier to reduce
the size of your JavaScript
code.
This saves your bandwidth.
It saves the users' bandwidth.
It starts up-- and the users'
application will start up
faster because there's less
JavaScript to parse and it got
there quicker because it
was a smaller file.
There are other minifiers
out there.
There's like JSMIN
and UglifyJS.
But most of them only focus on
minification, whereas the
Closure compiler also does
add status checking.
And we'll see more of that
in a bit as well.
The most important thing, I
think, about the Closure tools
that people don't realize, is
that the Library, Templates,
and the Compiler, they're
all independent tools.
You can actually use one of the
three on any JavaScript
project if that's all you're
interested in.
But they are, by far
and away, most
compelling when used together.
The results that you get, and
the improvement in your code,
are just much more compelling
when you put all these three
things together.
And I think that this is another
area where Closure is
far beyond a lot of the
other offerings.
There is jQuery, there Is
Mustache.js there is JSMin.
There are analogs for all
three of these tools.
So I can't claim that Closure
invented all these ideas.
However I think that most of
these other projects are done
kind of in a silo.
Whereas the Closure tools are
done knowing the strength of
each other tool in mind.
And that's why it really helps
to put them together.
To really understand and
appreciate the benefit of
Closure Tools, first I think we
should look at some of the
problems that JavaScript
developers face today.
And maybe you don't even realize
that you're having
this problem or that
you should be
doing something better.
So here's the first. People--
I don't know if anyone's used
the Library Prototype JS.
Prototype is a JavaScript
library that
goes way, way back.
And one of its claims to
fame was its terseness.
So this is a function that
Prototype offers.
Does anyone have a guess what
this function does, just by
reading it?
It does white space.
Yeah.
So it actually splits
your code.
It splits your string that you
give it, on white space.
Now if you know that, it's
probably because you've used
Prototype JS before.
But if you have a new person on
your project and they came
upon this function that says
dollar sign W, it's pretty
hard for them to come up with
what it does without, either
running it or looking
at the code.
And for one function
that's fine.
But if this is kind of how you
design your whole library,
basically to be unreadable but
terse, this is going to hurt
you when you're trying to
build a large JavaScript
application.
For a long time people have kind
of gotten away with, or
justified, this type of library
style because of
arguing that, well it's saving
my users' bandwidth because
I'm using fewer bytes for
my function names.
And so it's saving space on the
wire and therefore it's OK
to do things that no one
else understands.
But with things like the Closure
compiler, which will
rename variable for you--
as we'll see in a bit--
that's no longer as compelling
a reason to
do things that way.
So in the Closure world, you're
really going to want to
use names that are readable and
make sense and make sense
to your teammates and are
more self-documenting.
Another thing is building
up strings of HTML.
So the problem is, as I
mentioned, that JavaScript is
not really great at this, when
you want to preserve the
formatting of the HTML and the
structure that you're trying
to produce such that
it's readable.
You want it to be close to what
it would be if you wrote
HTML yourself.
But does anyone know what this
function would return?
So actually, this function, if
you just ran it, regardless of
what inputs you gave
to it, this
function returns undefined.
And the reason is that
JavaScript has this neat
feature called semicolon
insertion.
And basically if you don't use
semicolons everywhere, it
infers for where semicolons
can be placed.
And so, unlike some other
languages you can have logic
after a return statement
in JavaScript.
It's actually kind of helpful
during debugging if you want
to exit out real quick while
testing something.
But in your production
code, this is
actually kind of a disaster.
So what happens is, JavaScript
inserts a semicolon basically
after where that end
character would be.
Or the interpreter or the
run time does this.
It does this because then
there's a new line and then
this whole statement--
this on its own is a
valid JavaScript statement.
So the first line just
becomes return.
It returns undefined.
Actually that statement below
it never gets executed.
There's lots of little bugs,
errors, that people make
around this type of behavior.
And when it comes to things like
formatting HTML, it makes
it particularly worse.
Another problem that people
open themselves up to when
they write code in this manner
is that these arguments are
not HTML escaped.
Meaning that, if the user
is some sort of user and
potentially a malicious user,
is responsible for--
if you read these values out of
a database that that user
chose when they signed up or
filled out a form or something
like that-- if you don't escape
the less than signs and
whatnot before you blitz this
string of HTML into your
application, you could open
yourself up to a across-site
scripting attack.
Which is very embarrassing
for you.
I've done it.
I was very embarrassed
as you might imagine.
But it's better to have a tool
that really makes it harder to
make these kinds of mistakes.
Another issue is managing
dependencies in JavaScript.
I look at a lot of projects, or
even websites I visit, and
I wonder why they're slow.
And then I take a little look
under the hood and a lot of
them manage their dependencies
in this way.
And I can imagine what's going
through the developer's mind
as they come up with HTML.
So they're like, number one,
I'm writing JavaScript.
So I need jQuery.
Because everyone says
jQuery's cool.
So that's what I'm
going to do.
So they put a script tag to
jQuery in their page.
So far that's completely fine.
But then they get to the point
where they have some form that
needs people to input a date.
And they're like, I need
a date picker.
And they go and they download
a date picker library for
somewhere and they just plop
another script tag in there.
So now it's two tags.
Not so bad, right?
Probably going to need a date
picker in other places.
That's OK.
And then they decide that they
want some template solution.
Because actually, that would
kind of help them out.
And they didn't get one out of
box with jQuery or with the
data picker, so they
include that.
And then they started testing
on IE 6 and they're
like, ah, son of a--
Now I've got to add
this workaround.
And it's not that big, so
everyone can just get it.
It's just another script tag
and that type of thing.
And then, oh, actually, I also
forgot I should probably write
my application, too, while
I'm doing all this other
JavaScript development.
And you see lots of pages
like this, where
everything gets built up.
There's also a good chance
that unrelated template
solution dot js happened to
bundle jQuery in their
implementation.
And now you're pulling down
two versions of it.
I've seen a lot of
things like this.
So how long can this go on?
How many script tags can you
add to your web page?
Well, a lot, unfortunately.
And this is a big source of
slowness, if you've looked at
page feed or any of Steve
Souders's work on how to make
faster websites.
Everyone will tell you.
One, you need to minimize the
number of requests that your
page makes.
Sometimes you may want
to split things
up to leverage cacheing.
That really depends on the
profile of your page or the
assets that you're trying
to download.
But if you see something like
this, you're probably doing
something wrong.
And you could be doing something
a lot better.
And also, a lot of these
disparate libraries are
probably reimplementing the same
functionality and your
users are now downloading
it five times.
So managing dependencies.
Again, I said there's no
import statement in
JavaScript.
So it's somewhat difficult
to do out of the box.
Another thing that I've seen
happening recently is creating
a special version of JavaScript
for mobile.
Creating a special version of
your JavaScript for mobile is
a good thing.
Because they have different
capabilities and
that sort of thing.
But the problem is that when
I see forks of libraries.
So there's a library out called
Zepto .js and it's
basically a mobile web kit
implementation of jQuery So
when I say mobile web kit I
mean, you can rely on an array
having a for each library.
Or that you know that the
query selector method is
available in the DOM As opposed
to, in jQuery, to be
backwards compatible there's
substantial code that it
bundles to be able to emulate
query SelectorAll and
iterating of an array
and a whole bunch
of things like that.
And so instead of trying to
write one library, and not
repeating yourself, and then
doing some sort of
post-processing to generate what
would be a mobile web kit
optimized version and then
generating what's, let's say a
browser-agnostic version, people
sometimes just choose
to fork things.
And obviously then, it's much
harder to maintain.
You have two versions.
One has features that the
other one doesn't.
Testing.
All the efforts of what you're
trying to do are now doubled.
Another one is safeguarding
private variables.
Again, because we have no idea
of visibility keywords in
JavaScript.
There is no public
private keyword.
A lot of people use Closure to
emulate the private variables
in languages like Java.
And so this is an implementation
of how you
could do this if you imagine,
ImmutableLatLng, if you
treated that as a constructor.
You passed into lat, lng.
You wanted there to be
getters for these
properties but not setters.
This would do that for you.
The downside is that means every
time you instantiate one
of these objects--
in this case it's creating three
new function objects as
opposed to sharing one
method object.
So this will take
up more memory.
It also increases
look up time.
Because by using a Closure, you
actually create an actual
level of scope.
Newer engines like V 8 this
shouldn't actually be a
significant difference in terms
of the look up time.
But older browsers, like IE6,
these things actually become
more significant.
And another thing is
documenting types.
So as I mentioned we don't have
a standard syntax for
documenting types of variables
and methods in JavaScript.
But if you're going to have a
large application and people
want to be able to look at an
API really quickly, it's more
helpful if you have some
sort of standard
way to document types.
Sometimes libraries--
this is what Dojo does,
basically is that you can make
a little in-line comment.
And this is actually pretty good
as long as it's, you have
kind of a standard format.
But even in this example, you
have a method that takes some
number of parameters
and then you also
specify a call back function.
And a lot of people just say the
call back is a function.
But really, that call
back has a contract.
And in this case it
would be something
that takes a lat lng.
But developers right now usually
have to take a look at
the implementation of the method
to see what the call
back actually gets
or test it out.
Because it's not expressed in
the type definition that you
gave for the argument.
It's a lot easier to pick up a
library and use it if you know
what the contract of the
call back function is.
Helps you figure out where you
should send it or actually if
even if it's the right
method that you
should be using or not.
So these are a bunch of problems
that JavaScript
developers have today.
And so I want to go through the
Closure tools and let's
take a look at how Closure can
help you address these
problems, write better code and
avoid these pitfalls and
hopefully avoid bugs.
So the first thing is, this
is basically how--
when you use all the Closure
tools together--
how your application is built.
Or how you produce JavaScript
at the bottom.
So at the top, so one thing you
would have is you'd have
template code.
I'll show you in a second.
Closure Templates is its own
templating language.
So you write your templates in
that templating language.
And then you run it through the
tool, Closure Templates,
and that produces JavaScript.
So now each template that
you wrote becomes
a JavaScript function.
The Closure Library, as I said,
is already a library in
pure JavaScript.
So now you already have your
JavaScript library for string
and DOM utilities and all sorts
of other good stuff.
And then the third is your
application code.
So you're able to write code
that leverages both the
templates and the library code
that you've written.
And all three of these
things go down
into the Closure Compiler.
And so the Closure Compiler
is a whole program
optimize and compiler.
Meaning that it has all the
source code of your
application at once when
it compiles it.
This is unlike, let's say
Java, for example.
Where some of the assets that go
through javac are JARs are
pre-compiled objects and
therefore there's some
optimizations that the Closure
Compiler can do on a global
level because it has all
the source code.
And then as a result we get
some optimized JavaScript.
We get something that Closure
Compiler has produced knowing
all possible code paths, so to
speak, of your JavaScript
application.
And so this is what enables it
to produce something that's
really small, really compact
and really fast.
So the first thing I want to
show you is what the syntax
for Closure Templates
look like.
There's a namespace
at the top.
In this case I made a namespace
called widget.
The next, I guess this looks
kind of like Java or Javadoc,
where you declare the parameters
that are going to
be passed into the template.
So these are basically your
template variables below.
Then you have your HTML and
we have this dollar sign
placeholder type of thing.
Which, is probably not too
surprising if you've looked at
most other templating
solutions.
There's the markup and then
there's the stuff that you
want to insert.
At the outset, this maybe
doesn't look too compelling.
But what's more interesting is
that when we run this through
the Closure Templates tool,
and so this is what is
produced once you run
it through the tool.
So what's actually produced
is a function.
So unlike PHP, where PHP is
also a templating library,
where you can't really get
access to it programatically.
It's kind of like you
just hit the page
and stuff just happens.
Now this template is actually
a function.
It has, as a parameter
it has a return type.
You can see that it takes
this object in.
And another thing it does for
you is that, by default, you
can see that all the arguments
are escapes.
So I made that comment earlier
about my original definition
of a function that you'd try to
do this template, where the
arguments were not escaped and
you were subject to cross-site
scripting vulnerabilities.
In Closure Templates, it escapes
things by default.
You can add annotations to say
don't escape anything in this
template or don't escape
this variable.
But by default, you should
be a lot safer.
Another thing is also that
by this being a function,
something you can interact with
programatically, you can,
if you're familiar with the idea
of function carrying, and
also that in JavaScript that
functions are first order
objects, that you can
pass them around.
So programatiically, this is a
much nicer way to deal with
the idea of a template.
Also, you can see if you look
carefully, all the white space
that we put in the template--
just to make it readable
for ourselves--
is removed when it's
translated into
a JavaScript function.
So this saves bytes.
When you traverse the DOM
there's actually fewer white
space nodes that
get in the way.
So these are all nice things
and help you create markup
that's basically as trim
as it can possibly be.
Also I want to point out that
there's these statements that
got inserted at the top, which
are goog.provide and
goog.require, These are
functions that are part of the
Closure Library.
This is basically how namespaces
are declared and
how dependencies are expressed
in the Closure Library.
So as I said, there's no native
import function in
JavaScript but when you write
your code for the Closure
Library in this style, now you
have a standard way of
expressing dependencies and
we'll see the benefits of that
in just a second.
So the first thing is, now if we
have this template function
and now we want to use it.
So now this file we said
we provide this
namespace called widget.
Now we'll have some application
logic, where we
want to use it.
So now there's a goog.require
statement for widget.
And we're actually, ourselves,
going to provide a new
namespace called button.
So here, we add a method to
the button namespace by
declaring it as a property
on the button object.
And the button object got
created as a side effect of
running that goog.provide
statement.
And now we add it
as a property.
It's just a function.
All templates take one argument,
where the argument
is an object literal.
Where the names of the
properties are the values for
the template and the values of
the property are the values
for the template values.
And so basically we create this
data object and now we
can just pass it to
widget.button as a function,
return the value and return
that from get button HTML.
I find this to be--
many people find this to be--
much more maintainable.
Because now, when you want to
write your markup, you can
basically do it in any
way that you want.
You can actually put comments
in this template that don't
get included as part the
markup that's sent out.
And you really want
to write this.
But you don't want to
write it by hand.
But that's what you really
want produced.
And now you have that.
And now you can use
that inside your
regular JavaScript function.
So now we're just really
working in
the JavaScript world.
So as I mentioned, there's these
dependencies that we've
expressed through goog.provide
and goog.require.
So at the top we have button,
which we said requires widget.
And widget requires soy, which
is the internal name of
Closure Templates.
You'll see that if you look
through Closure code.
When you see soy it means
Closure Templates.
And in practice, Closure
Templates by default include a
bunch of stuff.
It includes DOM utilities
because a lot of times you
want to take the result of the
template and put it into a DOM
node or create a document
fragment out of it.
It includes string utilities for
doing the escaping and it
also includes a lot
of utilities for
internationalization.
So there's actually support
for internationalization.
In JavaScript Templates there's
a special message tag.
So if You're building an
application that you want to
localize, Closure Templates
helps with that as well.
But the thing is though, in the
example that I gave, we're
actually not using all
that stuff, right?
We never used the
DOM utilities.
We never used
internationalization.
A lot of people will choose to
maintain these dependencies by
hand saying, oh I don't want
to include all that stuff.
But as we'll see, the Closure
Compiler will take care of
that for you.
So it's OK to create large
libraries, where you, in
practice later, only use
some of the functions.
Because you're going to want to
supply these libraries to,
say, other teammates or
for other projects
that you maybe use.
So in practice, we'll see how
actually the DOM utilities and
the internationalization stuff
gets stripped out.
You don't pay some penalty for
using a more mature library.
So for example, in terms of
leveraging dependencies, we'll
introduce a new one
called myapp.
Now let's say this is
your application.
And now you require button and
you require some DOM utilities
and now you have a function that
goes ahead and uses the
template and inserts it into
the DOM with these standard
DOM utilities.
So now the dependency
graph for your
application has changed.
Now we have a new thing
at the root of the
graph called myapp.
It depends on button and
its dependencies still
go all the way down.
But now myapp depends on DOM.
And so now actually that DOM
dependency is going to come
back into our code.
But the internationalization one
will still be separated.
This is really nice because this
all happens naturally, as
we'll see with the
Closure Compiler.
As opposed to trying to manage
all those script tags by hand
and trying to figure out what
the dependency ordering is and
trying to find the minimal set
because you want to send down
the least JavaScript
code as possible.
Jumping right into the Closure
Compiler and looking at some
of the effects.
So the Closure Compiler, now
with code that is written in
the style, it understands
these goog.provide and
goog.require statements.
Now this is where it gets pretty
serious in terms of the
savings that it can give
you in terms of your
JavaScript code size.
So by default, if you just
concatenated all the files
that would be transitively
required, by that myapp.js
file that I created, it's
375K, approximately.
Very very, large.
That is a lot of code.
Especially for something as
trivial that we were doing.
We were just building
up some HTML and
inserting it into a DOM.
So that does seem
a bit excessive.
But then if you run the Closure
Compiler, there's a
mode called whitespace only.
Where all it does is remove
whitespace and comments.
This already gets you
down quite a bit.
So as you may guess, the Closure
Library is actually
pretty well documented
since that got rid of
almost 75% of the code.
So that's a pretty big
win right there.
By comparison, I also ran the
same code through YUI
Compressor and UglifyJS.
These are some other minifiers
that are popular right now.
You can see they do
a bit better than
whitespace only mode.
And the Closure Compiler also
has the simple mode, which is
analogous to the YUI Compressor
and UglifyJS.
And you can see it just ekes
them out by a little bit.
But we're not looking at an
order of magnitude of
difference.
Until we look at the advanced
mode of the Closure Compiler.
The advanced mode is quite
a different animal.
Basically what it can do is,
as I mentioned it's a whole
program optimize and compiler.
So it basically traces
the code paths
from the main method.
From this main method.
So this is the only function
that's actually called in this
application.
And it can trace through and
realize that, OK, the only
things that are called ate
getButtonHtml getElement and
so on and so forth.
And then when it's done
optimizing, it will only
include the bits that it needs,
that it's determined
that will be exercised by this
JavaScript application.
So now we've gotten down to
something that's 1/200 of the
original size of what we
were dealing with.
This is obviously a much better
way, to let a tool do
this for you than do this
type of thing by hand.
And even to go one step further
is that you can enable
options to eliminate
platform-specific code.
So if you have these special
defines, these special options
pass through the compiler, you
can say, assume that it's
mobile web kit and also assume
it's not JScript, which is the
engine in Internet Explorer.
And in this particular example,
this won't be true
for all examples, but it gets
the whole program down to 481
bytes, which is basically
nothing.
And this is all being done for
you, as opposed to you trying
to reorganize your code and
optimize it by hand in order
to get this same result.
So again, this also comes back
to, I mentioned that libraries
Zepto.js and jQuery where people
are making these forks.
Where instead if they were just
writing their code in a
way that you could eliminate
blocks of code using the
compiler, then they could share
much more of the common
code as opposed to having to do
a giant fork, which is much
harder to keep in sync.
So if we look, this
is the output
of the Closure Compiler.
It's very, very compact.
I was at the JavaScript
conference last week and
someone made the astute
remark of, I don't
want to be a compiler.
I want a compiler to
be a compiler.
And I think that's
a good adage.
But right now we see a lot of
people just trying to use
short variable names and some
other things and trying to do
it all by hand.
But no one is going to write
this type of code by hand,
even though this is really
what we want
produced at the outset.
And as your application gets
larger and larger, it's even
more important.
Because you can imagine, with
that example of five script
tags, you can imagine someone
growing their application to
be 20 script tags and then
someone copy-pastes it because
they think it's what they need
for their next project.
It's just not a way to do large
JavaScript development.
Especially when it's really
important that something
really compact, like what you
see here, is the result.
Another important thing to think
about as well is that,
as our applications are getting
larger in JavaScript,
that there's a lot more IP,
intellectual property, that's
going into these things
that we are
sending down to our users.
And if you've built a very large
JavaScript application,
and now say, you're putting it
in the Chrome Web Store or
various other places, you don't
want to be giving your
source code away, necessarily.
So even though it's not the
primary goal the of the
Compiler, it also effectively
serves as an obfuscator.
It makes it much more difficult
for someone to take
the code that they get and then
add their own features to
it and then claim
it as their own.
So that's another aspect, I
think, that's kind of unique
to development in the large
right now, is that the bulk of
the code is so much
more interesting.
It took you so much more time
to build up, if you're doing
it for business reasons, that
you need to have a better way
to protect it.
Also, as I mentioned, there's
no type system built into
JavaScript natively.
So one of the better ways to
approximate it is by using
basically something
like annotations.
And this is what we see here.
We have some JS stock, as we
call it, and where we have--
we have app param tags
like you're kind of
accustomed to from Java.
But then the thing in curly
braces is what's called a type
expression.
And it basically says, this is
the valid types that can be
passed in for this argument.
We also have this annotation
for a constructor.
So that basically says that, if
the compiler sees you using
this LatLng function but not
using it with the new key
word, it will yell at you.
Because it recognizes that
this is the constructor.
It's something that's meant
to be instantiated.
It's not an ordinary function.
Similarly there's also this
app private annotation.
And it's not on by default but
you can add a check to the
Compiler that says, make sure
all accesses to something
annotated with app private are
only done from what's inside a
Closure class.
So again, as opposed to creating
those somewhat clunky
closures, now you have a way
that better communicates what
you're trying to do, much
more succinctly by
just saying app private.
It also eliminates that run time
overhead, you had before,
of creating a closure.
Now instead of calling a getter
method, the Compiler
can change those getter methods
into direct property
look ups, it can in line them,
and this can further reduce
code size and improve run
time performance.
Also that these type
expressions, they also enable
static typing.
So the Compiler also has logic
to enforce your types.
So just something that you're
accustomed from the Java
compiler or any other very
strongly typed language, this
is something that you can turn
on and have it check to make
sure that the contracts
that you've
declared are being honored.
It actually is able to work with
partial type information
in that you may not
document the types
for all your functions.
But where you do, the compiler
will leverage it and where you
don't, it'll basically
make a best effort.
But it shouldn't return
false positives.
Finally there's a rich type
expression language.
So as I mentioned before, we
often see things where someone
just declares a callback.
Now there's actually a standard
way, or at least from
the perspective of the Closure
Compiler, so that you can say,
this is a function that takes a
LatLng object, which may be
null, which is what the question
mark at the front of
that LatLng signifies.
You can also specify if it's a
var function, the type of its
return type.
This one didn't happen to
have a return type.
And this is a win, both for
the Compiler, because it's
able to do type checking
on more complex
expressions like functions.
But also for your developers,
because they can go and run
through the code and look
really quickly.
Like, oh I just need to pass a
function that takes a LatLng?
Excellent.
As opposed to having to dig
through the code to figure out
exactly what it does.
So to try to bring all together,
JavaScript code
bases are getting larger.
I think the Chrome Books
announcement today is also
very exciting in this regard
in that people are going to
want to make bigger
and bigger apps.
They're going to have to be in
JavaScript at some level,
either translated from GWT
or writing them directly.
Especially if you want
them to work offline.
Because then all you have
when it works offline is
JavaScript, HTML and CSS.
So as we are bringing more
complex applications to the
web, these code bases are
going to get larger.
And JavaScript, unfortunately,
was not designed for
programming in the large.
And so one way is to try to
escape it and run to another
programming language.
But another option is to try to
tame it, so to speak, with
the Closure tools.
And that is what, in
my experiences,
worked quite well.
And so I encourage you not to
run from JavaScript but to
give it a big bear
hug instead.
But use the Closure tools
to tame it so that your
application can grow but
not grow out of hand.
So thank you very much.
And I now have time
for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Yep?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure I know
anybody who's starting on a
really big JavaScript project.
We already have JavaScript
projects and we're probably
not using Closure tools.
Very few people are outside
of Google, I feel like.
How do you transition a very,
very large project--
I mean the sort of project that
would actually benefit
from Closure tools--
onto it without like, OK well,
we're just going to spend the
next three months writing
comments?
MICHAEL BOLIN: So I think,
like any migration, you
certainly want to
do it in pieces.
And you obviously don't want to
hold up, prevent yourself
from making any sort of forward
progress while you're
in transition.
So the first thing I would say
is using goog.provide and
goog.require, having some
scaffolding to express the
dependencies in your
application.
I would say that is step one.
Step two is then, you probably
have some existing logic for
things like registering event
listeners or array utilities.
And then I think what you do is
you choose one at a time to
swap out what your home-brewed
solution with the Closure
Library equivalent and then
you progressively do that.
This is also what happened
inside Google.
The Library didn't exist
forever and we had long
running applications that
were already built up.
And it was the same problem.
Because you don't want to just
copy it all in in one day.
Because then your application
doubles in size and that's not
really great for your
users either.
So I think you definitely want
to stage it and you definitely
want to pick.
Create the scaffolding with the
require and provide and
then move things in
as you go forward.
AUDIENCE: I should clarify.
We're already using Dojo
provide and require.
So we already have something
in place.
Certainly we could replace
them with googs.
No problem.
But it's actually really the
Closure Compiler, which seems
like it's an all or
nothing thing.
Like either everything is marked
up with comments so it
knows what to delete or it
deletes your application.
MICHAEL BOLIN: As I showed, the
Closure Compiler does have
different modes.
So there's simple mode,
for example.
AUDIENCE: I really want
advanced mode.
That's where I feel like
I get the big benefit.
How do I ever get there?
It's a million miles away.
MICHAEL BOLIN: I think that
some people in the Dojo
community, well I'm sure more
than some, are interested in
this as well.
Another thing you can do is, the
compiler is open source.
It is written in Java and it has
its own plugin system such
that you can write new
compiler passes.
So if you have a large, if you
feel like your code base is
too large to migrate, the right
thing to do, or the
simplest thing to do--
as simple as writing
compiler code is--
but is to write your own pass.
Fortunately the Closure
Compiler has a
lot of passes already.
And they're also very
well unit tested.
So if you break something
it'll be pretty clear.
And you also have a lot of
sample code to go off.
So you might want to write your
own pass that understands
Dojo a bit better.
And then that may be the best
way for you to leverage it.
AUDIENCE: So we don't have
a lot of, even Dojo
doc common in there.
MICHAEL BOLIN: What
do you have?
AUDIENCE: We've got comments.
We've got sort of ordinary
comments.
But we didn't make type
parameter comments.
Who would, right?
What's the point of those?
MICHAEL BOLIN: Type checking is
an option of the advanced
mode to get the minification.
It's not a requirement.
So you don't have to have
everything marked up with type
expressions to even use advanced
mode, necessarily.
It's more helpful if you do but
it's not a hard and fast
requirement.
AUDIENCE: Can I, if I have
half my code marked up--
or really, a hundredth of my
code marked up with type
parameters can I use
that at all?
MICHAEL BOLIN: Yeah,
absolutely.
So basically every time omit a
type expression, it assumes
that the type expression would
be asterisk, which
means the any type.
And so it already has
mechanisms to
deal with that situation.
AUDIENCE: So if I replaced
all my Dojo requires with
goog.requires and run the
advanced Compiler, what's
about to happen?
It's going to delete
my [? location ?]
right?
MICHAEL BOLIN: There are some
other caveats that are
actually well documented
on the website.
In terms of things like quoting
properties, is a
common one.
That's probably the biggest one
off the top of my head.
But I think most Dojo code
is pretty similar.
So I don't think it would be a
disaster but there's a very
good page on code.google.com
that says hazards of using
advanced mode.
And it should help you
audit your code for
those types of things.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We have a pretty big
JavaScript project.
Probably a couple megs of
source or something.
Big project.
But we switched over to the
Closure Compiler last summer
and we've been totally
thrilled with it.
But this is the first time
we've seen the Templates.
And I think it's something
we're interested in.
I am curious-- because it looks
like you have to run a
compiler pass just to use them--
is there any, so I
know, like, we're using the
advanced mode compilation but
you can run it uncompiled
and the
goog.requires just do XHR requests.
Get the code and eval
them and stuff.
Is there an equivalent for those
templates, that you can
run them straight from source?
Because at this point, running
the compiler takes some time.
Because it's a big project.
MICHAEL BOLIN: So built a
tool, for some reason I
neglected to put it
in my slides.
It's called Plovr.
My O'Riley animal is the golden
plover, so I named my
tool Plovr, without an e because
I wanted to be cool
like Flickr.
But if you take a look, what it
does is it has some modes
that basically you can just
point it at a directory of
JavaScript in Closure Templates
files and it will
just spin up and serve
them from disk.
And the JS ones it will serve
verbatim and the dot.soi files
for Closure Templates, it'll
translate them on the fly.
So you're development, you can
still debug what is basically
raw code but not have to run the
compiler over everything
to get that.
Because I understand that
for larger code
bases it is a bit slower.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I actually have
two questions for you.
The first question is about
browser native functionality.
The Closure Compiler, is it
smart enough to detect that
kind of functionality?
And then, if so, when new
browser-capable features come
out, what's the delay time
between the library being
updated versus not and being
able to support those.
MICHAEL BOLIN: That's
a good question.
So basically you're writing
in JavaScript.
So if it's there you can you
test in JavaScript as you
normally would.
You could say, if document.body
query selector
all and then do one thing.
And if not, do another thing.
But there's also this idea,
when using the compiler in
advanced mode, this idea of
what's called externs.
Where you basically say, these
are all the symbols that are
going to exist in the
environment in which my code
runs and their type
definitions.
So document and window and
that sort of thing.
Because as you saw, the Closure
Compiler renamed a
whole bunch of variables.
But it can't rename the
built-ins, like
document and window.
So when you're talking about
browser features, those are
usually listed in these externs
files that declare
basically what's in the
browser environment.
Those are updated pretty
quickly, I would say.
Because a lot of projects,
people
are pushing the envelope.
In that sense the compiler,
the time between a feature
coming out to being used by the
Compiler, or available or
recognized by the compiler
is pretty small.
AUDIENCE: My second question
was about development.
It looks like you don't get that
minified code until after
you've run through the compiler,
which makes sense.
When I'm doing actual
development and I'm debugging
with Firebug or Chrome's
developer tools, do I have to
load up all 150 or whatever
megabyte of
those library files?
MICHAEL BOLIN: It depends
how you do it.
So one thing you can also do
with the Closure Compiler,
which I didn't demonstrate
today, is you can have this
idea modules.
So GWT has this idea of code
splitting, where you can say
when I'm only using up to this
feature, then only include
these JavaScript files.
And then if the user starts
using this other feature, then
pull down these other files.
So one really good technique is
to use this modules feature
of the compiler, which
ultimately will compile
optimized version of each of
those clumps of code and will
depend on the symbols that
exist in the code that's
already loaded.
So basically, you're only
loading the minimal set of
files for the functionality
you need right now as the
user, say, goes to the
settings page.
And now the settings code,
now it'll pull that down,
basically on demand.
And this works in
development too.
So it will only be the
individual files that
contribute to, what I'm
calling a module.
So, no, you don't have to
necessarily load everything
when you start up.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Does this one work?
MICHAEL BOLIN: Sorry.
I didn't see you.
The lights are bright.
AUDIENCE: This relates to
the first question.
You had that one slide, where
you had the prototype with the
dollar sign w, I've used Closure
to do some newer
projects, but I have
a lot of legacy
projects with Prototype.
Will the compiler deal with
those types of commands, to
compile them down?
Or do you have to pretty much
remove all the Prototype to
get the compiler to work?
MICHAEL BOLIN: Well no.
So if you supply the Prototype
source code as an input to the
compiler, it will treat it
like any other input.
And also if--
so unused functions will then
also still go away.
And interestingly, if you have
a function that you use a lot
in the Closure Library and it
has a very verbose name, the
compiler will pick the smallest
names for the
functions that are used the
most. So possibly your
prototype functions could get
renamed to longer things,
although they're only two bytes
so it's probably not.
Actually it would be longer.
But basically, sorry,
the short answer to
your question is yes.
You can use the Prototype
code with the compiler.
AUDIENCE: So one of the most fun
things in the world about
doing JavaScript is after you've
minified it, that you
get a bug report
from the field.
So is there an equivalent to a
symbol table or something that
could be added in say, a
less-than perfectly optimized?
MICHAEL BOLIN: Yep.
So basically there's an option,
when you run the
compiler, to output as a
byproduct, a thing called a
source map.
And so it is a reverse mapping,
it's actually every
line and character in your
compiled code, to the line and
character position in the
original source code.
And then there's some other
Java code that's there for
taking a JavaScript stack trace
from the server and
converting it into an obfuscated
JavaScript file.
The only caveat is that, you
really care about the line and
the character offset.
And I believe right now, only
Chrome-- and I guess probably
then Safari--
provide both the line
and the character.
Most of the other browsers
only do the line.
I haven't checked Firefox 4, but
at least Firefox 3.6 still
only sent the line number.
So if anyone has influence over
any of those folks, it'd
be great if they also sent
character offsets.
Because, to exactly the point
that you're making.
AUDIENCE: Is Closure planning to
implement the common module
dependency, CommonJS standard?
MICHAEL BOLIN: That's
a good question.
So there is no plan
and there's no
anti-plan as far as I know.
In that they're not hating on
it and they maybe haven't
figured out exactly how to
merge the two worlds.
I think, if there were a good
proposal put forth on how to
combine those two things, I
think the people who work on
Closure would be
very interested
in making that happen.
AUDIENCE: Are you still
working on Closure?
Or is that something Google
works on and you
don't work on anymore.
MICHAEL BOLIN: I contribute
to Closure for sure.
And I certainly talk
to those folks.
We had a discussion just last
week about it and it was kind
of like, one of the many items
on the list. It's certainly
something that we'd like to
address but it hasn't bubbled
to the top yet.
Anybody else?
Thank you, everyone.
I hope you enjoy Google I/O.